POINTS AT ONE JUNCTURE BEFORE
CLOSING OFF 287.
S&P 500 DROPPED 11.
NASDAQ DOWN 21.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTS HE'S --
CHINA CALLS HIS LATEST MOVE
BLACKMAIL.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON HAS
MORE TONIGHT FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PROMISES
A SECOND ROUND OF TARIFFS
AGAINST CHINESE IMPORTS AND IS
THREATENING A THIRD.
GLOBAL MARKETS DROPPED WITH
LOSSES ACROSS ASIA, EUROPE,
UNITED STATES.
THE PRESIDENT CONTENDS HE'S
CORRECTING A STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
IN U.S. TRADE POLICY.
>> YOU SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH CHINA.
WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
THAT SHOULD'VE BEEN DONE MANY
YEARS AGO.
>> DIRECTING THE UNITED STATES
TRADE REPRESENTATIVE TO IDENTIFY
$200 BILLION IN CHINESE IMPORTS
AND APPLY A TARIFF OF 10%.
CHINA RETALIATES TO ME SAYS HIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL RAISE
TARIFFS ON AN ADDITIONAL
$200 BILLION IN CHINESE GOODS.
THAT IS ON TOP OF THE TARIFFS
SIT IN MOVEMENT OF LAST WEEK ON
$50 BILLION IN CHINESE IMPORTS.
CHINA RETALIATED AND SAYS IT'S
NOT AFRAID OF A TRADE WAR WITH
THE U.S.
>> WE ADVISE THE U.S. TO REMAIN
RATIONAL AND STOP SUCH WORDS AND
MOVES THAT HARM ITSELF AND
OTHERS.
IT IS THE ONLY VIABLE WAY OUT.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALSO ENACTED TARIFFS ON GLOBAL
STEEL AND ALUMINUM IMPORTS.
RUSSIA ANNOUNCED TODAY IT WILL
SOON RELEASE A LIST OF AMERICAN
PUBLIC PRODUCTS TO TARGET.
AMERICAN ALLIES SAY THEY WILL
RETALIATE.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT CLAIMS
ARGUMENTS WILL NOT AFFECT OTHER
ASPECTS OF INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
>> ENCOURAGING YOU NOT TO
CONFLATE THE TWO ISSUES.
WE HAVE COMPLEX RELATIONSHIPS
WITH SO MANY COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD WHERE WE HAVE THINGS
WITH ARE IN TOTAL DISAGREEMENT
OVER AND AREAS WHERE WE ARE
WORKING TO DEVELOP BETTER
AGREEMENTS.
>> SOME ANALYSTS DISAGREE
ESPECIALLY ON CHINA AND ITS
INVOLVEMENT WITH NORTH KOREA.
>> THEY ARE NOT WITHOUT LEVERAGE
ON THIS.
WHY IMPOSING TARIFFS ON THIS ON
THEM WILL MAKE THEM MORE
COOPERATIVE, I DON'T SEE.
>> LESS THAN A WEEK AFTER THE
SINGAPORE SUMMIT, NORTH KOREA
DICTATOR KIM JONG UN IS IN CHINA
AGAIN.
HIS THIRD TRIP THERE TO MEET
WITH PRESIDENT XI JINPING.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS THE
UNITED STATES AND NORTH KOREA
HAVE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS
SINCE LAST WEEK'S SUMMIT IN
SINGAPORE, AND NOW TO U.S.
DEFENSE OFFICIALS SAY
NORTH KOREA IS EXPECTED TO
TRANSFER THE REMAINS OF 200 U.S.
SERVICE MEMBERS KILLED DURING
THE KOREAN WAR.
DOING SO TO U.N. COMMAND IN
SOUTH KOREA.
THAT WAS ANNOUNCED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP LAST WEEK AT THE
SUMMIT.
>> Bret: INTERESTING, THE
THIRD TRIP BY KIM TO CHINA.
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCING
THE DEPARTURE FROM THE UNITED
NATIONS MADE HUMAN RIGHTS BODY.
>> CALLING IT A SHAMELESS
DEFENDER OF HYPOCRISY.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO JOINING U.S. AMBASSADOR
NIKKI HALEY HERE ABOUT AN HOUR
AGO, SAYING IT HAD GIVEN THE
U.N. HUMAN RIGHTS COUNCIL A YEAR
TO REFORM ITSELF.
IT FAILED TO DO SO, SAID THE
U.S. IS LEAVING.
>> WE TAKE THIS STEP BECAUSE OF
OUR COMMITMENT.
IT DOES NOT ALLOW US TO REMAIN
PART OF A HYPOCRITICAL AND
SELF-SERVING ORGANIZATION THAT
MAKES HIM MOCKERY OF HUMAN
RIGHTS.
WE COULD HAVE WITHDRAWN
IMMEDIATELY.
WE DID NOT DO THAT.
INSTEAD, WE MADE A GOOD-FAITH
EFFORT TO RESOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> SECRETARY POMPEO SAYS THE
COUNCIL HAS MEMBERSHIP ON SOME
OF THE WORST HUMAN RIGHTS
DEFENDERS, CHINA, CUBA,
VENEZUELA WHILE IT MISTREATS
ISRAEL AND LETS OTHER VIOLATORS
GO.
CHRIS COONS SAYS IT'S A MISTAKE
FOR THE UNITED STATES TO LEAVE
AND IT'S BETTER TO BE PART OF